you were watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
remember nokia you know that company
that used to dominate the mobile phone
industry in the late 90s and early 2000
the company that could do no wrong until
it of course did well after a swirl of
unconfirmed whispers and rumors the
company from Finland is returning in
2017 as most of you probably know nokia
was losing massive market share to
Android and the iPhone in the late 2000s
but refused to get on to the smartphone
game early when they finally did get
into the smartphone game they took a
gamble and decided to use Microsoft's OS
instead of Android this of course meant
that even though Nokia's build quality
camera and hardware was pristine
the main complaint from users was that
there were no apps this didn't bode well
for Nokia and eventually Microsoft
bought the device and Services Division
of Nokia after this they ran it straight
into the ground part of this contract
between Microsoft and Nokia was that no
Nokia branded phones could be released
up to 30 months after the deal now that
30 month period has just passed and
Nokia can create their own devices again
and wear their brand name proudly
according to the website know your
mobile there's going to be two models a
mid-range phone and a flagship handset
the flagship phone is set to go
head-to-head with the Apple iPhone and
the Samsung Galaxy s8 for those
interested in the technical details the
rumors are saying that the flagship
phone is going to have the as yet
unreleased snapdragon 835 cpu with 6
gigabytes of RAM take that with a grain
of salt of course so the interesting
thing is Nokia itself isn't going to be
making the phone but they kind of are
I'll explain what I mean in a second so
Nokia no longer has the manufacturing
facilities to make the phone but they're
going to be collaborating with a
brand-new Finnish company called hmd
global as well as the Taiwanese
manufacturer Foxconn the reason I said
that Nokia kind of is going to be making
the phones again is because hmd global
was actually founded by veteran Nokia
executives these X NOK your employees
founded the company in May 2016 after
purchasing part of Microsoft's mobile
division
press-release hmd said that they were
going to develop market and sell the
nokia branded phones and accessories
while Foxconn is dealing with R&D and
manufacturing Nokia is going on an
all-out marketing campaign blitz this
includes contracting the largest
independent advertising firm in the UK
mother and I think this is probably the
best part of this story more often than
not companies screw up major
opportunities like this because they
just don't get the marketing and
advertising right advertising campaigns
must be memorable and resonate with
potential customers and has to get that
sales leverage point across clearly with
previous clients like Google Microsoft
coca-cola IKEA Calvin Klein the mother
advertising agency seems a promising fit
for Nokia so looking from a broader
perspective I think it's cool that a
bunch of ex Nokia staff got together and
form their own company hmd global to
take Nokia back from the grave and make
it rise again will of course see what
happens but I'm wishing them all the
best so that's just a quick summary and
update about Nokia coming back but if
you want to know exactly what happened
to knock here in the first place I want
to know about their history I have a
three-part series on this channel about
that exact topic it's called the rise
and fall of Nokia I'll leave it in the
description if you want to check it out
anyway thanks for watching guys and if
there's not a video before the new year
happy new year and I hope it's a great
year for you guys Cheers
have a good one cold fusion its me
thinking
[Music]